TO BE NEEDING A LOT OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL HELP GOING
FORWARD.
>> MICHAEL, GENERAL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>>> SO THEY FLED KYIV JUST DAYS
BEFORE THE RUSSIAN INVASION BUT
THEY DIDN'T FLEE THE COUNTRY.
AMERICAN JOE RHYMERS AND HIS
UKRAINIAN WIFE DASCHA WENT WEST
TO LVIV WHERE THEY'RE NOW
HELPING REFUGEES FIND PLACES TO
STAY AND THEY BOTH JOIN ME NOW.
HELLO TO BOTH OF YOU.
I AM SO GLAD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
JOE, WE'LL BE SPEAKING SINCE I
UNDERSTAND DASCHA IS CONCERNED
ABOUT HER ENGLISH BUT, PLEASE,
IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY,
DASCHA, FEEL FREE TO JUMP RIGHT
IN.
THIS IS YOUR PLATFORM AND YOUR
TIME TO SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT.
SO AGAIN, WE ARE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
JOINING US.
JOE, YOU JUST GOT MARRIED IN
JUNE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AFTER LIVING IN UKRAINE FOR
FOUR YEARS NOW.
DID YOU EVER IMAGINE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS WOULD HAPPEN?
>> NO, AND I GUESS THAT IS ONE
OF THE MANY PRIVILEGES OF BEING
AN AMERICAN, RIGHT, IS BIG
PROBLEMS LIKE THIS ARE ALWAYS
THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
AND THEN I MOVED TO ONE OF THOSE
COUNTRIES AND NOW WE'RE HERE.
BUT IN ALL THE READING WE DID
ABOUT THE FIRST YEAR OF MARRIAGE
THIS WASN'T SOMETHING WE WERE
PREPARED FOR.
>> YEAH.
SO LET'S TRY THIS.
AND JUST SEE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> YEAH.
DEPENDS.
SOMETIMES SAD SOMETIMES ANGRY.
WE ARE TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
JUST TO, FOR NOT TO THINK ABOUT
MY FAMILY ALL THE TIME.
BUT YEAH.
WE'RE DOING OKAY HERE.
>> I IMAGINE IT'S TOUGH.
YOUR LIFE HAS BEEN UP ENDED IN
THE LAST TWO WEEKS.
JOE, HOW DID YOU HAVE THE
FORESIGHT TO GET OUT OF KYIV?
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I THINK, YOU KNOW, HONESTLY
WE CAN'T EVEN REALLY SAY IT WAS
OUR FORESIGHT.
WE FELT LIKE WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO AND THE
REPORTS WERE GETTING MORE
CONCERNING, AND MY PARENTS IN
AMERICA I THINK WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT IT AND SO WE --
AND ALSO DASHA'S FAMILY WAS IN
MARIUPOL, HER 13-YEAR-OLD SISTER
WAS THERE, AND WE WERE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IN THAT PART OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY WE THOUGHT
TO HAVE HER SISTER COME TO US SO
SHE WOULD BE AWAY FROM ANYTHING
THAT MIGHT HAPPEN THERE SO THAT
AND ALSO MAYBE HELPING MY
PARENTS TO SLEEP A LITTLE BETTER
AT NIGHT WE DECIDED TO COME AND
NOW OBVIOUSLY WE'RE THANKFUL
THAT WE DID.
>> YOU FEEL SAFER THERE BUT IT'S
STILL, I MEAN, LVIV IS, YOU
KNOW, THERE IS TROUBLE THERE AND
YOU'RE NOT IN COMPLETE SAFETY
EVEN THERE, JOE.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, THAT'S ALL A
GUESSING GAME.
IT DEPENDS ON, YOU KNOW, WHAT WE
READ ONE DAY I'LL BE SURE THAT
THERE IS NO WAY PUTIN WILL TRY
TO EXPAND THE WAR THIS FAR WEST
IN THE COUNTRY.
OTHER DAYS YOU'RE NOT SO SURE
ABOUT THAT.
BUT WE FEEL THAT WE'RE SAFE HERE
FOR NOW.
WE FEEL WE ARE ABLE TO DO
IMPORTANT WORK WHILE HERE SO FOR
NOW WE HAVE MADE THE DECISION TO
STAY.
>> YOU ARE BOTH LIVING IN LVIV
ALONG WITH DASHA'S SISTER AND
BROTHER 18 AND THEREFORE CANNOT
LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVEN'T
LEFT UKRAINE IN PART BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO STAY WITH THEM.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> YES, THAT'S RIGHT.
SO AS PROBABLY A LOT OF YOUR
VIEWERS KNOW MEN FROM 18 TO 60
CAN'T LEAVE THE COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW UNLESS THEY HAVE THREE OR
MORE KIDS OR I THINK THERE ARE
SOME REALLY NARROW MEDICAL
EXCEPTIONS TO THAT.
AND SO WE DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE
HIM HERE WITH DASHA'S FAMILY
ALSO IN MARIUPOL WE DIDN'T FEEL
RIGHT LEAVING AND THEN ONCE WE
GOT HERE TO LVIV LIKE I SAID WE
JUST FELT LIKE THERE WERE THINGS
WE COULD DO HERE AND WE FELT
THAT THE SITUATION HERE WAS SAFE
AT LEAST FOR THE TIME BEING.
>> DASHA, HOW IS YOUR FAMILY
DOING?
>> THEY ARE HIDING IN THE CHURCH
BASEMENT FOR THE LAST NINE DAYS
NOW AND THERE IS NO WATER, GAS,
ELECTRICITY IN THE CITY.
OF COURSE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
WANT --
>> THEY'RE NOT LETTING THEM
EVACUATE THE CITY.
>> YEAH.
AND ALSO THEY WON'T LET SOMEONE
ELSE TO BRING HUMANITARIAN HELP.
SO THEY WERE PREPARED FOR THAT
FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND.
AND THEY HAD ENOUGH FOOD AND
WATER FOR THEMSELVES BUT THEN
PEOPLE STARTED COMING TO THE
CHURCH AND THERE ARE MORE THAN
20 OF THEM THERE NOW.
SO WE TALK RARELY.
THAT CONNECTION VERY BAD THERE.
SO I DON'T KNOW.
>> THEY DIDN'T EVACUATE BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO TAKE CARE OF YOUR
GRANDMOTHER, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
THEIR FIRST IDEA WAS NOT TO
LEAVE BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF HER AND NOW SINCE LIKE
THEY FOUND A THING TO DO THERE
SO THEY HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THEY FEEL RESPONSIBLE FOR AND,
PLUS, NOW THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
THE ABILITY TO LEAVE EVEN IF
THEY WOULD WANT TO.
>> HOW LONG DO YOU THINK THEY
CAN HOLD OUT IN HIDING UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES?
>> WE -- THAT'S HARD FOR US TO
KNOW BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, CELL
SERVICE IS SO LIMITED THERE
RIGHT NOW.
WE TALKED TO DASHA'S DAD VERY
BRIEFLY YESTERDAY MORNING AND
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME WE HAD
BEEN ABLE TO GET ANY
COMMUNICATION FROM HIM FOR ABOUT
TWO AND A HALF DAYS BEFORE THAT.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT WHEN WE
TALK TO THEM, THEY'RE DOING
THEIR BEST NOT TO SCARE THEIR
CHILDREN ABOUT WHAT THE
SITUATION IS REALLY LIKE THERE
SO WE DON'T KNOW A LOT OF
SPECIFICS ABOUT HOW MUCH
SUPPLIES THEY HAVE.
I REMEMBER NOT THIS LAST TIME
BUT THE TIME BEFORE WHEN WE
TALKED TO THEM, DASHA'S DAD
SAID, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A BETTER
BASEMENT THAN A LOT OF PEOPLE
HERE IN THE CITY SO WE CAN'T
COMPLAIN.
SO HE'S, YOU KNOW, MOST OF THE
FAMILY IS STAYING THERE IN THE
BASEMENT, BUT HE WORKS WITH AN
ORGANIZATION THAT CARES FOR THE
ELDERLY AND WIDOWS IN THEIR CITY
AND SO HE HAS BEEN GOING AROUND
FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND TO
DELIVER THEM FOOD AND SUPPLIES
AND FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND HE
WON'T LEAVE UNTIL ALL OF THOSE
WOMEN ARE ABLE TO LEAVE AND MANY
OF THEM ARE, YOU KNOW, LIVE IN
THEIR BEDS.
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO REALLY WALK
ON THEIR OWN SO IT WOULD TAKE
SOME KIND OF MASS EVACUATION I
THINK TO GET THEM OUT WHICH SO
FAR HAS NOT BEEN POSSIBLE.
>> LET'S TALK A LITTLE MORE.
I WAS LOOKING AT MY NOTES AND
YOU TOLD MY TEAM THAT ALMOST
EVERYONE IS INVOLVED IN THE WAR
EFFORT.
AND OUR REPORTERS HAVE SEEN
PEOPLE SETTING UP ROAD BLOCKS,
WOMEN MAKING CAMOUFLAGE NETTING,
PEOPLE TAKING UP ARMS, EVEN
CIVILIANS MAKING MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU BOTH HAVE
BEEN HELPING REFUGEES FIND
PLACES TO STAY.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT?
>> YES, SO WHEN WE CAME HERE WE
WERE IN A SITUATION WHERE WE
WERE IN A CITY THAT WE HAD ONLY
TRAVELED TO A COUPLE TIMES
BRIEFLY AND DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO
STAY AND, YOU KNOW, THANKFULLY
WE GOT HERE EARLY ENOUGH THAT WE
WERE KIND OF ABLE TO LEARN OUR
WAY AROUND THE CITY A LITTLE BIT
AND DASHA HAS AN AUNT AND UNCLE
AND COUSINS LIVING HERE SO SHE
GOT PRETTY CONNECTED WITH THE
COMMUNITY HERE AND STARTED DOING
A LOT OF THINGS BUT ONE THING
SHE DID IS KIND OF MADE A
DIRECTORY OF PLACES ALL AROUND
UKRAINE THAT ARE TAKING IN
DISPLACED PEOPLE AND REFUGEES,
PHONE NUMBERS THEY CAN CALL, AND
JUST STARTED CONNECTING PEOPLE,
PEOPLE WE KNOW AND CONTACTS WITH
PEOPLE WE KNOW IN KYIV OR OTHER
PLACES IN THE COUNTRY WHO FLED
HERE AND HELPING THEM FIND A
PLACE TO STAY BECAUSE AS I'M
SURE YOU'VE HEARD THE WESTERN
PART OF THE COUNTRY HERE IS JUST
OVERWHELMED WITH DISPLACED
PEOPLE.
>> DASHA, WHAT DO YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW ABOUT YOU, YOUR
FAMILY, YOUR COUNTRY?
>> I WAS THINKING ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE YOU NEVER WANT TO BE
THIS PERSON PEOPLE ARE WATCHING
ON TV AND FEEL PITY FOR, RIGHT?
AND WE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE.
WE HAD NORMAL LIFE HERE.
WE WERE HAPPY.
AND WE JUST WANT THIS TO COME
BACK.
WE JUST WANT THIS BACK.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN HELP
US SOMEHOW WE'LL BE GRATEFUL.
>> DAS